gravity falls can't wait to see this
next episode episode six you guys keep
saying it gets better and better and you
know what it has been getting better and
better you've proven yourselves not to
be liars
full-length watchalongs your single
gravity falls or our patreon page cover
a bunch of shows over there as well
right now if you don't want to do that
just at least hit the like button i mean
the world let's get to it thanks to the
boys of prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights
we're hungry
as soon as this yahoo makes up his mind
do you have this in another animal
i'm fine locking him inside if you are
locking him inside oh my god
puma shirt panther shirt oh my shirt
panther shirt feel like zac alphadocus
to play that guy in real life i'm
sitting here wondering if the voice
actor was uh the guy who plays mcgruber
whose name i'm now blanking on
well forte there you go but it would be
a real-life zack galfinacus character
make it rain
where were you yesterday i got hit by a
bus
hilarious
oh no
maybe
[Music]
plus a free salad dressing for the lady
and a small plate of ketchup for the boy
but grunkle stan i want pancakes with
the fancy flower they use these days
what am i made of money
oh
uh oh you got no muscles you smell like
baby wipes and let's not forget last
tuesday's
incident
that girl is you
don't come in don't come in you are
listening to girly icelandic pop
sensation baba no baba
you see this chest hair oh
my eyes
oh man
get ready to eat your words
and a plate of delicious pancakes
god i want pancakes and two quit stalin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on buddy
oh
poor guy
this thing must be broken it's totally
broken guys it's like a million years
old probably ran out of steam power or
it's rickety man you shouldn't even
oh no
yeah
pancakes for everyone
you still got what you wanted man you
still got the pancakes lesson learned
stop there
third thank you there sugar pot i i mean
honey wasp kitten baby baby cow
silly silly man what was that about
nothing i uh i don't want to talk about
it man's got a crush
it would be nice if she liked me but
i've been out of the game for so long i
wouldn't know where to start i mean look
at her she's so classy
[Laughter]
you are a cranky gross weird old man but
we will get lazy susan to like you
because nothing is stronger than the
power of love
mabel to victory
[Music]
the power of mabel
another hydrant destroyed it's a gosh
dang mystery want to take off our
uniforms and run around in circles
quit reading my mind
oh
i'm sorry i was looking for the mailman
oh what are you saying i'm not a male
man
is that what you're getting at are you
crying
oh
buddy
hey men can cry
gonna finish that no
can't believe it part animal part human
are you some kind of minotaur i'm a
mandator half man
half
half tour
i got problems manatar man related
problems
hey you know you seem pretty manly maybe
you could give me some pointers hmm
very well climb atop my back hair child
oh my
dude watch out
yes
[Music]
wow man heart cave the gnomes live in
the trees the mer people live in the
water because they're losers but we
manators crash in the man cave
i have brought you
a hairless child
sup huh this is uh puberty testosterone
[Music]
my name's dipper
the uh destructor
yeah that's better
dipper the destructor wants us to teach
him the secrets to our manliness he's a
human i don't like him i don't like your
face
let's start out with some role playing
just will play lazy susan i'm soft like
a woman
show me how you approach a woman
remember this is a safe non-judgmental
environment i'll just be right off to
the side judging you on a scale from one
to ten
can i borrow some money
after a lot of punching we have decided
to deny your request to learn our manly
secrets
denied
denied
why that's okay with me obviously you
guys think it would be too hard to train
me maybe you're not man enough to try
uh oh
the hell you say
he didn't mean it i have three y
chromosomes six adam's apples picks on
my abs and fists for nipples
oh my
some red and snippy [ __ ]
being a man is about conquering your
fears for your first man task you must
plunge your fist into the pain hole
it's like dune yeah you got this
pelatrades
smile harder
harder
sup bam bone what do you think
sandwich
[Music]
you got a dream
[Music]
[Laughter]
know what's happening
[Music]
you wish to be a man
then you must do heroic act go to
highest mountain
oh yeah
bring back head of
the multi-bear
he's our sworn enemy conquer him and
your man's formation will be complete no
no no no no no
i shall no
the multibear
[Music]
you're pretty good at this man yeah
grown quite a bit
i'm coming for you multi-bear
okay grunkle stan you started like this
but you became
oh no oh
god
no no no
is that throw up on your shirt
i don't know how to answer that
face it mabel your uncle unfixable like
that spinning pie trolley thing in the
diner
[Music]
what is a multi-bear
disgusting
child why have you come here multi-bear
i seek your head or one of them anyway
there's like what six six heads
[Music]
why can you imagine the show actually
goes there yeah it's
blood everywhere but will you grant a
magical beast one last request
ah okay i wish to die listening to my
favorite song ah no
tape is already in there you can just
hit any jm that's it press and hold
all the manators make fun of me because
i know all the words to the song disco
girl oh you mean disco girl
coming through
that girl
i guess i'm supposed to kill you or i'll
never be a man i accept my fate no
you're the real man
malty bear you keep telling me that
being a man means doing all these tasks
and being aggro all the time but i'm
starting to think that stuff's malarkey
oh no
shattering paradigms
kill the multi-bear or never be a man
and i guess i'll never be a man
[Music]
[Laughter]
i know he's not much to look at but
you're always fixing stuff in the diner
and if you like fixing stuff nothing
could use more fixing than my grunkle
stan also women live longer than men so
your dating pool is smaller and you
should really lower your standards
here's my number
why don't you give me a call sometime
here's some pie on the house for you
[Music]
dipper it's me mabel i'm looking at you
through the glass
[Laughter]
what's wrong i don't want to talk about
it good it's just these half man
you were your own man and you stood up
for yourself
huh yeah you did what was right even
though no one agreed with you sounds
pretty manly to me but what do i know
oh that's nice
this is amazing i really do take that
man tester take that pituitary pituitary
this guy has chest hair
oh
message number 36
hey handsome it's me lazy susan calling
to say hi hi
it is jennifer coolidge
say hi donald
good sandy you say hi
mr cat face now it's your turn to see
mr cat face
anyway call me call me back
how do i get out of this
typical man
only in it for the chase that's right
typical typical men
men disgust me i hate all men
please continue that's decision no no no
no men are all so monosyllabic we don't
talk much we keep things bottled in yeah
do your thing
i know i know there's more
nora's more that pond of john rifts oh
yeah
i really don't have anything
i don't else a screen today not a bad
episode whatsoever i quite enjoyed it it
was really
really i thought that i had like
probably one of the best
learning lessons for all genders
out there not just men
not just men
but you know
the lesser ones non-men the lesser
genders yeah all the all those genders
below
yeah manliness manhood baby back yeah
all right we're filming
i'm gonna shut this door now
okay
it's a very manly conversation you just
have there huh oh no she was yelling at
me yeah that's true
but you know
you did what you wanted anyway yeah so
that's what men got to do
want to do it right
well i really i thought like the writing
of this was pretty solid because you
have uh i don't really know why i mean i
think that's like a that's a common
thing for like little boys is to try to
become like feel more manly at a certain
point i think that's very common uh to
achieve that level of masculinity you
know and
uh so i like the journey that he goes on
but it's really like the beginning and
end that i think is really well done
of
you know like he wasn't getting his
uncle's approval and was being mocked at
by him and by his uncle and mabel
and for not being manly enough like he's
really being clowned on and he goes
through this like wild journey and he
doesn't be doesn't get crowned man
yet
by him deciding to make his own choice
and stand up for himself going against
you know convention or peer pressure
when he know when he's standing up for
what he truly believes is right or or
the choice he wants to make
that without realizing it he's become
more of a man than before with having uh
and then his uncle even approves of what
he did yeah and he doesn't even realize
that
you know he's gonna be like it's like
his uncle's those names like he's trying
to approve of him yeah but that's what
he's like it's sort of seeking and then
on the flip side too
with demonstrating what
men can be like when they're older with
grunkle stan and
you know after he gets the girl too it's
pretty it's
it's funny you know this is some of
these are these are uh themes for men
that i think are really well honed in on
here of high masculine testosterone
fueled energy and really it's just about
being true to yourself is like just like
any other human being i think uh versus
you know
com the stereotypes
like beating up homeless people or
something yeah yeah it's very it's the
manliest thing i could think of that's
what we were pressured to do we were
younger yeah eating
like a whole drum of protein powder
yeah
made out of chicken breast eggs yes
yeah just 100
meat protein yeah
but you know some of the
like really it's the the comedy part is
like the subjective angle it's like i
really thought the beginning and ending
were really funny but weirdly all the
high octane stuff i didn't find as funny
the whole thing with the uh mandators i
don't know why i was like always amused
but i wasn't like huh this is this is
some of the best comedy they've got in a
while yeah maybe because i've been
exposed to so much of the uh toxic
masculinity humor or the narcissistic
yeah egotistical type of dumb guy
humor which i do love i do eat it up but
but i don't know i guess i'm just so
used to it by this point that i don't
really like so much comedy that i've
seen is mainly that yeah well that's
fair i mean i think the joke doesn't
especially evolve beyond a certain point
once you get to the world of the
manators and all that like it almost
feels like just the fact that they are
what they are this this you know
mythological form of masculinity
incarnate uh you know like that
kind of feels like the joke maybe
plateaus a bit from there because a lot
of
what comes is like you said amusing but
not like
inspired to the point where it's like oh
that's a masculinity joke i haven't
heard before or haven't heard that many
times uh but yeah i would agree that the
surrounding sort of qualities of the
episode kind of approaching the concept
of manhood from you know before and sort
of after the prime that you're searching
for made for a nice complimentary a and
b story because yeah obviously dipper is
going to go out and challenge himself
and i thought that was a really nice
conclusion of like this manliest thing
you can do is even surrounded by like
who you regard to be the pinnacles of
that you know
type of being
even still you did what was right and
what you thought was the best choice and
so that was nice and then having grunkle
stand on the opposite end doing this
sort of like the posturing of you know
trying to appeal to a lady and having to
you know reign in some of the crazy or
masculine or just the things that you
don't really
bother to maintain when you're uh you
know older and in that position perhaps
so yeah it was nice complimentary and it
all started over pancakes and that's
always a good
catalyst for me
yeah
well i think both stories the take away
messages
to just
be true to yourself that's like
literally what happens with both of them
is they just they're just
have to succumb to being themselves and
not trying to be anything else other
than who they are
and i i feel like the the most
manly
i i think
you know i'm not exactly
the manliest man in the world
well
typical standards
john's more manly than me nah dude have
you seen how big your biceps are it's
like the manliest thing possible they're
tiny you just lift all day and you're
not in here shooting vids you're just
out there lifting this up
dude you own half the city just
kicking down fire hydrants absolutely
who needs
who needs to be able to put out a fire
robin banks and suits that's manly for
sure yeah the
the
um
i think that the thing that i i at least
identify with
in terms of
because i feel like this is just a human
trait i don't feel like it's a manly
trait i feel like the cliche of man is
you know face your fears
and i think a lot of the time
men
have a hard time facing their feelings
they're like kind of afraid of their
feelings yeah and
believe me i get what that's like and i
i feel like the biggest thing you can do
as a person
and especially for going up against the
concept of manhood when facing your
fears
is to not be afraid to face your
feelings otherwise it manifests into
rage
testosterone and
all kinds of other things that men are
cliched for yeah so yeah i think feeling
your feelings and being honest with
yourself and i think that's why the
message is really nice because at the
end of the day it's about being true to
your character more than anything else
that's what men this will real men
actually do
and real women and real anybody that's
the scene mainly men mainly men though
men are the ones with convictions men
have to pave the way for
that way women
know what to do you can feel and then
when they start feeling their feelings
and i'm like why are women taking our
feelings now yeah geez it was this is
not cool though just get all the
feelings you just can't what why are we
gender swapping everything
you know what i mean
they can't feel too
they can't rob banks or or casinos you
know with befriend a monkey or be a
friend of mine that's not a womanly
thing to do with no it's not even or
like go on a big revenge spree because
somebody killed your teenage daughter no
those movies tank for a reason yeah
that's right we got four john wicks one
atomic blonde
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't worry peppermint will become a
franchise any second now yeah we'll get
a salt sequel it'll be great so yeah
anyway guys are you a man leave your
thoughts down below if you're a woman
um
copy other men and type
type away yeah even though we invented
the typewriter
all of us together
one
piece at a time i don't know
the typewriter i believe a woman
invented the internet
really yeah
i think that's like i think it was a
female like a former i think there's a
person actually in hollywood
and then
olivia
she's gone she's dead okay she died
turns your off switch on i'm not out
there absolutely her officer yeah dying
he's manly
it depends
how'd you die
how did i die was it like
uh like uh uh like did you die like from
like a
you know like getting hit like by taking
a bullet for someone yeah i took one of
those big like super mario bullets it's
like the size of your whole body it's
too child friendly it's not manly enough
that's how a woman would i took an
exploding bullet
four of them all converged on my head at
the same time as i took the c4 away from
the burning orphanage
with all the kids on my back before i
dropped them safely onto like a bouncy
castle and jumped into a gorge to
explode that's almost too manly yeah
i wouldn't i wouldn't get that man and
while i was doing it i grew a beard in
real time
just like on the spot
it's like right before my head explodes
just like rasputin beard
okay
i don't feel inspired when i talk to you
you don't want to emulate
my plays of glory manliness
come on now
well it's like very well feral humor in
this episode yeah yeah that's good cause
it's like exactly what so much of his
characters are making yeah
like pig-headedness
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below
here we are now hey let's do a pic
chris wham-off just listen to the last
name wham-off doesn't get more manly
than that he comes from a family where
there's literally only men it's an
anomaly how did he be born into this
planet through natural birth yeah and
just get right out of a bicycle no one
knows there's no woman out there in the
wham-off family purely men it's all y
chromosomes it's pretty insane to know
that we have one of the most manly
people over at our patreon page he's
constantly sacrificed everything in
order to make the world better doesn't
get more manly than that sacrifice jobs
his reputation
his livelihood his family friends
friends random folks he runs into you
don't want to google this guy don't ever
look up he's giving it all up in the
most manly ways
by helping other people out it doesn't
get more manly than being able to
have the greatest distance from everyone
else
that yeah is manliness that's where you
get that thousand-mile stare so chris
wham-off thanks for inspiring me to be
more of a man like you
i have officially scheduled the day with
the channel shuts down
that i blow up this home
don't worry
only
the cats and my woman will be in here
okay you won't be here john all right
they're gonna die
people are gonna feel sorry for me
i use that pity to be like an [ __ ]
okay
it's very manly but most people won't
know
that like totally why is he such an
[ __ ] yeah what are they going to find
out the great loss i had yeah
that's attractive that is yeah nothing
is sexier than crippling grief chris
wham-off
taught me
that
[ __ ] pity is the way to go oh yeah oh
yeah so stop feeling sorry for yourself
everyone this video has been done 10
minutes ago what are you still doing
here
[Music]